the Euro stronger this morning won 25-22
yes come down quite a way since the
middle of June when it was approaching
what 140 back in the early summer we
come right down to 125 I set the scene
for you here in Europe the European
commissioners slashed growth forecast
this for this year and for next to 0.8
percent for this year to 1.1 percent for
next year we're expecting rates to
remain at record lows in the eurozone a
benchmark rate of 0.05 percent a deposit
rate a negative deposit rate of 0.2
percent but we sit here once again
Scarlett asking the same question what
more can the ECB do John I read that
European Commission report it sounded
almost passive-aggressive like well you
know all we're saying this community
consumer demand is low but you know you
do whatever you want it was it a signal
wasn't a signal look it's confirming
what a lot of people already thought you
see the rate decision confirmed where I
said unchanged unchanged unchanged but
going back to the forecast we've seen we
saw forecast today from the OECD as well
Brendan and those forecasts actually had
a little bit of a punch line they said
the ECB needs to get a little bit more
aggressive and to go out there and buy
assets aggressively whether they can do
that really aggressively in the same way
the Bank of Japan has that remains
firmly in doubt John what's the question
that people will be asking Mario Draghi
that he won't be able to answer today at
830am they're always the best questions
aren't they Scarlett I think the number
one question for a lot of people is can
you expand the balance sheet in the way
you desire with the stimulus measures
already announced because if you want to
get it up a trillion euros with what
you've announced so far a covered bond
purchase program and asset-backed
securities purchase program isn't enough
to boost the balance sheet without
sovereign QE the question goes on and on
and on and on the other question let me
throw this back at you is the theatre
the soap opera that the ECB has become
this week because this week reports have
circulated that members of the governing
council are set to challenge Mario
Draghi's leadership qualities well let's
I mean let's go and let's take a look at
the theater let's let's read the yellow
press on this I want to go back to that
European Commission report they wrote I
thought this was funny the longer the
recovery of the EU remains weak the less
convincing becomes the argument that
this is the typical pattern to be
expected following a deep financial and
monetary crisis which you can only
follow with the word duh but is that
sinking in over there I think eventually
it has to Brendan it's sunk in with the
ECB they really have done a lot over the
last six months a lot more than they
have done in the past under the likes of
tree che they've done much more under
dragging that is without doubt but it's
really the argument the fiscal side that
just keeps going on and on and on
Germany why are you balancing the budget
why are you telling France they've got
to get the budget deficit down to three
percent there's no sign of them doing it
anyway you need to stimulate demand in
the economy and to do that we've got to
loosen things up on a fiscal side and
structurally as well and that is not
happening